the place i want to be happy and proud
is my own life first then
the rest of the world is open but
whatever happened outside the country
will happen but i wanted i wanted to
make sure that i'm happy and i feel
comfortable from coast to coast that was
the most important thing
be gentle with yourself i mean people
expect to be chefs when they give about
between 40 and 60 hours to their
day job time night day job and you
expect to be a chef just
just be gentle with yourself try it
first
we are not restaurants so if you're good
with 10 recipes
make them you don't have to try to
recreate the will
each time just enjoy them your family is
going to be happy
if everyone is dying with recipes then
make some others
but you don't have to always recreate
everything
people put too much pressure and then
i'd say
keep close to your roots don't try to be
something your family or yourself
or not it's very important
and it's not about you know health and
all that it's about just you what makes
you happy because having a meal
cooking for yourself for your friends
it's very intimate
it's something you are going to share
something that's going to help you bond
with the people you like
whether they're three at the table or a
friend or a new boyfriend or
food has this capacity of bringing
people close to each other so i'd say
that remember this
the rest is only technique and if the
magazine is well done mine or any other
if you follow it you should have a great
result
i brag to say that the best results are
in mine
but the fact are if you look at the
recipe
and you follow it why shouldn't it work
it
should work you should be able to obtain
success
i'm specific in the things i love you
know like
i'm crazy about sketch one for the
vietnamese restaurant that
by night the first time i i drank a nice
coffee but
to me saskatchewan is camping in the
badlands it's going
you know south of willowbunch and going
there to me it's like this
the full sunset is much nicer than favax
people are crazy about
the sunset in the mountains you have to
go to saskatchewan that's the place to
see the sunset
but also my father is from the maritimes
from the gas phases so
to me to to have the ocean breeze and
the seaweed
and all that and and the party on you
know the rocky beach
with a fire and that that's another
thing
so i'm very into nature and because
restaurant changes all the time so
i love to go a place where there's
something unique that is different i
love everything that's different
i try to teach this to my children don't
try to be like others
we have to be different this is why we
travel
to meet different people different
culture different food
so throughout the country i'll say let's
be specific let's create
things so i'd say like in vancouver
when i go there and the thing is also
because now i have friends quite often i
don't go as much as restaurants because
i go to eat at their houses and i see
what they're cooking
better but it is better when someone
else is cooking for hungry
but at the same time you go to see it
you go to have a sandwich at meat and
bread
close to glaston and they have this
bacon ice cream sandwich
it's crazy it's crazy you go to rose and
sun and try you go
yeah i have places like this cafe quebec
and
there's all the places i love
actually i'm like a bit in therapy with
you because i realize that
i like very personal places we do
and and places where you feel the heart
and soul of someone behind the bar
beyond the kitchen
at the service and they can tell i love
stories
i talk too much obviously so i love when
someone can actually talk to me about
what i eat
where i am why are they preparing this
that way because that feeds me more than
actually a recipe i can create a recipe
but what changes my vision
to transfer it to a magazine are the
stories that people tell me
why do you like me okay and how do you
prepare your steak and
why do you use that spice i will use
this
and work at it and create something
that's very accessible to every canadian
i'm working on one i can't talk about it
but i'm working on one
but i have to say that this is
my bb for the last two years and it took
time
i traveled a lot throughout the country
i wanted to make sure that it would be
what as canadian we needed and wanted
so now that this is out there i feel
free to really you know start a new show
and
give everything
i never feel the same